this is meh come on from reach robotics
he's a four-legged but battle bot and
each leg has three degrees of freedom
with the two servos on the hip and one
in the knee and it means he's kind of
nimble it can run around you can make
some motions you can say hello to you
I'll just collect him so everything is
controlled through a phone apps he
and the idea is if you've got two of
these little guys they can battle with
little IR transceivers in each side so
we've got one of each major direction
and what they'll do is they'll fire IR
signals at each other and we'll know
when we've hit or miss we're also
working on augmented reality gaming so
my particular particular area of
expertise is computer vision augmented
reality so that's kind of where I come
in and the idea will be that we can put
your mech Aman in your living room have
it interact with the space it can battle
it can fight it can shoot and it can do
that either with another Mecca Mon or it
can do it but playing at one of our
virtual AI Mecca Mon as well so he's got
things like say he likes a bit of a
dance
let him finish dancing and then he can
hopefully write himself it's a bit slow
P out here so he might struggle in this
in this kind of terrain is more of a
living room liver we've got things to do
with our battling so he'll he'll do kind
of offensive lunges sometimes he's got a
bit of an itch yes the scratch we have a
range of things you can play around with
you can change his body height so on
some terrains you might want him a bit
higher obviously higher is the mauryas
like to follow this oh you might also
want to lower and down to the stability
you can change where the legs are so if
he's on a narrow platform oh there again
he's on a narrow platform he can balance
or if he's on a slope he can fall over
we can increase how far out is stances
and obviously bring it in it's all
highly controllable through the multiple
servers we've got sitting within
obviously you and your friend can get
one they can battle but also you might
want to play by yourself using augmented
reality or you might want to teach him
to move yourself one of the things we're
quite keen on is that people can enjoy
robotics as a whole it doesn't just have
to be about the Mecca Manas is we want
to inspire people and let them have fun
so we've got an app called Mecca motion
where you can position the legs you can
teach him moves you can say alright I
want this leg here I want this leg here
you can build up a series of movements
almost like stop animation and the mecca
one will learn how to move between those
hopefully coming up in the future is a
visual programming kind of language
based roughly around the idea of scratch
so you'll be able to have kids
programming the robot and having fun
with the robot without necessarily
having to know how to get stuck deep
down in the code
eventually we're also having to have an
SDK that people can use to work it
the robot more in a more fine-grained
way as well I'm a computer vision
engineer so I first heard of reached
robotics who make the mecha mon about
four years ago when I was doing a
postdoc in the Bristol robotics lab
which was just as they were starting out
there in the startup incubator there and
then it just so happened I worked for it
as a postdoc for a couple years I moved
into industry and then I just saw a job
application for each robotics and I
thought recognize that name and I
thought I looked it up and it looked
like a really interesting job building
augmented reality around such a cool
platform they really wanted to inspire
people everyone there is really
passionate about making robots and
making cool things it was just a
brilliant brilliant place so I should
say this is a kind of development bill
that I've been testing on but I can show
you show you part of it so what I'll do
is if I disconnect the robot I can show
you some of our AR functionality
outdoors it's a little bit untested
we're more of a living room state at the
moment but so what I'm doing now is
building an idea of where the ground is
using some of the cutting-edge augmented
reality techniques are available on
mobile phones so there's a are kitten AR
core libraries from Google and Apple now
it's asking me to explore the play space
so I can kind of look around and I don't
know if you can see on the light but
it's building up an idea of what's
around what I'm going to show you is
augmented reality app so at the moment
I'm building up an idea of where the
ground is just by showing it a little
bit of the ground space it can map out
what what represents a ground and what
represents say a wall or a chair or a
table so I tell it yes you have found
the ground and then it's asking me to
you know have a look around find where
whereabouts I can move the robot and you
can see it's kind of building up a
picture of what's movable ground and
what what it can't work on throws out
some scenery elements and now we can
play the game this is something of a
development build at the moment with
still a work in progress but the idea is
I'm the silver robot we've got the gold
robot there and I can fight the gold
robot using my attacks if I was using a
real robot there now I would be able to
take on the properties based on the
kind of things that are mounted on my
robot so we have these atoms so we can
put shields on and off and different
numbers of shields will allow you to
have different abilities in game and you
can attach different weapons different
rifles and these will again allow you to
make different attacks within the game
and so if you have maybe more weapons
that you can carry fewer shields because
of the weight that sort of idea and it
adds a bit more strategy to the game and
means it as you as you kind of move on
with the mech one you can build it in
your way that you're interested in and
so the other thing is it's entirely
modular so we can take a leg off the
robot we can fill it back on and it's
it's a uniform connector so all the legs
fit whichever side of the robot you're
on so the aim with the AR is that if you
own a robot but maybe your friends don't
you can still play with your robot you
don't have to be left just kind of
running it around you can get involved
with for in this case you can have a
battle but we're also looking at kind of
more arcadey style games things like
asteroids head games and it means that
you've kind of got the scope to enjoy
your robot and as we develop more games
you'll be able to play more games with
it with it as well and also the mode you
just saw is the entirely virtual mode so
you'll be able to play augmented reality
games in the magma come on the universe
without necessarily owning a mecha Mon
and then there's another connector here
which is a serial connector and that's
going to little IMU measurement system
so I can basically correct the body
attitude according to gravity and level
the Machine off but was straight across
the bottom and the screen was in in
landscape and we had the menu the a B
and the joystick buttons